overall it seems like it's a lovely love
story it is between you and Emilio
because it now this sounds are you lying
I mean he is your only and only real yes
he says I don't know any better that's
why it's good September but there is
something and it does sound annoying
there is a quality in him that does
annoy you well it doesn't really annoy
me it actually makes me very happy
because he makes me laugh all the time
he's gotten business neurons in his
brain and music and he's focused on all
that but he is the most absent-minded
individual you will ever see he has left
me places forgetting that I was with him
when he went where and this is before
cellphone days so he goes no I don't
want you to get wetted sprinkling 45
minutes later backstage where is he I
call home he was there you you forgot me
with me he has this other funny thing
that kill he has a direct connection
between his brain and his mouth he
doesn't really edit anything so whatever
pops into his head first fortunately I
speak Emilio so I can usually figure it
out but like things like this the other
day he comes up to me he goes look Tom
Cruise as he points to his shoes and I'm
going Tom Cruise Tom Cruise and I was
thinking cuz Tom Cruise had been at her
home if we'd had a dinner and I go did
he give you that as a gift what what
what Tom Cruise he goes get the designer
I go Tom Ford
[Laughter]
you know what he calls one the Queen of
Soul urethra Franklin flying out of
Vegas
and he goes look there it is notre damn
I go it's over dad laughing I think
that's what we've been married 40 years
[Music]
you